I think we realize it nearly immediately
I think I can tell you something about
that yes actually to be clear our work
was kind of a general theory we were not
sure to what it would apply actually we
thought first he would apply to the
strong forces which was a mistake but we
then realized that is by 2 electron with
horses but we didn't make the theory
that was won by Weinberg Solomon show
her the Nobel Prize for that and there
have been a lot of Nobel Prize connected
to to to this theory height first number
twice for the electroweak theory the
number part for the fact which was very
important in which we were completely
aware of from the beginning which is the
fact that it's valid quantum
mechanically which was proven in a
beautiful way by dr. Venkman they got
the door prize there was a discovery by
particles at CERN the W and the Z boson
which transmit which have mass and
transmit the weak interaction and that
was also a Nobel Prize all of these were
essentially that based two particles to
do what we constructed as a theory but
of course there's a lot of things to be
added to get all of that and it took
time and well and the point is that
after let's say 83 1983 when will
discover the W and the Z we were totally
convinced that the theory was true but
there was still an alternative either it
was mediated by a condensate of objects
the sea which was not
the balls on or it was the bolts which
were condensate we in our original paper
put both hypotheses and didn't know
which one is the right one and at that
moment in 83 it was Dylan to which was
the right one and it is the discovery
turn that would select the right one
which is one of the two hypotheses we
put in 1864 so I have a bit deviated
from your question which is when do we
realize of course we didn't realize all
of that that's obvious but we realize
that I think it was a break too because
we thought that for the first time
there's a way to understand how
interaction fundamental interaction
which acts between object which are very
close to them and are not felt at large
distances that's called short-range
interaction that that could work and
actually so I remember without part
which was my friend and which we work
together after that also for years and
that we went to a cafe that I still see
very well and we ordered the bottle of
champagne and we said and that was I
think a few months after happy and the
artist so we had the impression right we
were a little bit sad that people didn't
seem to hear i said but ought to pay
attention let's say they were good
reason not to pay attention at that time
because they were adopting mix but i
think we had died we were convinced by
the way we did it we didn't have a proof
at that time that it was consistent
quantum mechanically but the way we
constructed it which is very beautiful
at that time based on Oscar field theory
and we had the impression that that at
the end would work and so we we
celebrated we might have celebrated
wrongly but at least
we brought the champagne and it was fine